Let us make this example
a little bit more complicated.
Complicated enough that it cannot
be proven simply by applying
one instance of modus ponens.
Imagine that a robot proved to itself
that this box is not liftable.
And the humans in the factory
who were trying to make
fun of the robots said to the robot
well, the reason it's not liftable is
not because it's not movable, but
because your battery is not working.
So now the situation
is more complicated,
the robot must also check its battery.
So now the robot begins with
slightly different knowledge in this
knowledge case.
So suppose that the knowledge in its
knowledge basis, cannot move and
battery full means it's not liftable.
It finds from its concept.
Again, it cannot move, so it checks its
battery, and it checks its battery and
it finds that the battery's full.
So then two new sentences that get
written in the knowledge base.
By the knowledge base
contains three sentences.
As earlier, the resolutions you're
improving, the agent must convert
all these sentences, in its knowledge
base into a conjunctive normal form.
That means that the sentences
can contain a literal or
a disjunctional literal or
a conjunction of disjunctional literals.
So if we begin by removing
the implication from sentence one,
because an implication cannot occur
in a conjunctive normal form.
So when we remove implication from
the first sentence we get this sentence.
Where the sentence is not yet
satisfactory, it is not yet
a conjunctive normal form because this
is a disjunction of conjunctions.
And what we want are conjunctions
of disjunctions.
So we apply the deMorgan's Law and
now we get the following sentence.
We're simply taking the negation inside
which flips the conjunction into
a disjunction and now we have three
liftables connected with disjunctions
and this is a conjunctive normal form,
disjunctional liftable.
So now we have in the knowledge base,
three sentences, all three of them in
the conductor normal form, either
literals or disjunctional literals.
Recall that the robot wanted
to prove not liftable.
So it takes the negation of that,
this is again proof by refutation, so
it considers liftable.
So now this knowledge
base has four sentences.
These four sentences coming from
the negation of what it wants to prove.
Once again the reasoning begins by
the literal that it wants to prove,
in this case liftable.
It finds a sentence in which
the negation of literal is true.
So once again,
we begin with the sentence,
S4 because that is
what we want to prove.
And we find a sentence in the knowledge
base which contains a literal
which is a negation of the literal in
this sentence S4 that we want to prove.
We resolve on this because
they both cannot be true, and
resolution here simply
means that we drop them.
Now, in the sentence S1 that is
under consideration currently,
we have two literals.
We can begin with either one of them.
Let us begin with not battery full.
We'll try to find a sentence
which contains a negation of
this particle electrode.
There is a sentence, S3, which is a
negation of this so we resolve on this.
Battery full and not battery full
because they both cannot be true.
We'll drop them.
Now in sentence S1 we are left
with just one literal, can-move.
We can try to find a sentence in
the knowledge base which contains
a negational judge literal.
Here it is, and so
we can resolve on them.
And we resolve on them, we drop them.
And once we drop them,
then we have a null condition,
which stands for a contradiction.
So we reached a contradiction, therefore
the assumption that this was liftable
cannot be true, therefore not liftable
is true, and we have just shown that
resolution theorem proving in this case
proves what the robot wanted to prove.
One important point to note here is
the issue of focus of attention.
Often when the problem space is very
complex, for example, when the number of
sentences is really large, the sentences
are very complex, it can become really
hard for the logical agent
to decide what to focus on.
But because we have converted everything
in a conjunctive normal form, and
because resolution theorem proving is
making use of resolution, therefore
at any particular time, the logical
agent knows exactly what to focus on.
You always begin with this literal,
you always try to find a sentence
which contains this negation.
You always resolve on that.
You take the remaining literal in
the sentence and proceed forward.
This focus of attention, this
computational efficiency of resolution
theorem proving is arising because
a [INAUDIBLE] called horn clauses.
A horn clause, is a disjunction that
contains at most one positive literal.
This is happening in S1.
This is a disjunction that contains
at most one positive recall.
This is a negative recall,
this is a negative recall, and
the fact that it contains
just one positive recall,
is a very powerful idea because that's
where the focus of attention comes from.